bonsoir et bienvenue en qui est ce que
votre magazine culturel alors au menu ce
soir gonelle roussel et illinoise auteur
de musiques compositrice interprète elle
vient de lancer une souscription sur un
site de financement participatif pour
réaliser un seuil et d'un capteur
elle est l'invitée de kiosques les 5 et
6 mars prochains la ferme de bel ébat
avec lui en propose
nous attendrons que le soleil revienne
elle vit quoi j'avais rencontré l'auteur
godefroy ségal
c'est en ce moment le festival femmes du
monde à magny les hameaux des
conférences des animations des ateliers
proposés pendant tout un mois l atelier
peinture a par exemple vient d'être
organisée et il faut voilà ce que l'on
peut découvrir dans ce nouveau numéro de
kiosques on passe toute la page musique
des magazines invité de cette émission
grenelle roussel bon soir dans un grand
auteur compositrice interprète vous êtes
dans le milieu musical depuis une
vingtaine d'années et vous avez lancé un
projet de financement participatif pour
la réalisation d'un cd 4 titres pardon
il ya un premier financement qui a été
arrêté au 13 février puisse vous en vous
venez d'en relancer un autre qui va
durer à peu près de moi oui c'est ça oui
oui jusqu'au 14 avril pour réaliser un
donc un quatre titres qui s'appellera
femme de merlin et dont on va peut-être
voir
premier extrait avec la verna votre
nouvelle box financement participatif il
ya hauteur de 4000 euros et sûrement un
site bien connu qu'on peut citer qui est
nul
oui peut vous retrouver mais avant qu'on
voit cet extrait parlez moi d'amour de
votre univers est assez particulier
alors c'est un c'est un univers
effectivement à coloration on va dire
celtique
je suis moi-même bretonne
et donc c'est vrai que je baigne depuis
toute petite danse est dans cette
ambiance et dans cet univers celtique
ainsi que des légendes qui me passionne
donc je réalise finalement avec ce
projet d'album
c'est une concrétisation de tous ces
univers qui me plaisent depuis depuis
tout petit et votre mini vert c'est
aussi la recherche de la nouvelle quête
oui alors anglais alors en fait ses
chansons racontent une histoire c'est
pour ça que je parle véritablement d'un
projet musical
parce que cette histoire c'est
effectivement l'histoire de la nouvelle
quête c'est la quête de l'harmonie et je
pense qu'elle est parfaitement résumée
par la chanson merlin merlin
l'enchanteur et la fée viviane merlin
qui a été enfermée dans une tour d'air
invisible par la fée viviane qui voulait
le garder
rien que pour lui et cette chanson
raconte que selon la prophétie ils se
retrouveront dans une nouvelle vie ils
se reconnaîtront parce que leur leur
amour est toujours là et toujours
présent mais cette fois ci ils vont
tâcher de vivre
une vie de couple en harmonie juste un
homme juste une femme en harmonie alors
maintenant on va regarder voir est
effective allez salut qui s'annonce très
bien ce qu'on va regarder dans le clip
berlin le premier titre
oui
c'est vous le preuve
par grand sourire
quinze jours
sept rallyes est bien sorti
vugar
et que sa complice
c'est
non
mais je vous demande est bonne elle
s'était tournée ou forcée des andes non
on a un peu triché parce qu'on n'avait
pas les moyens de les risques en forêt
de brocéliande ça à montfort l'amaury
casser le rêve s'est effectivement
premier titre merlin vous avez vous êtes
d'origine bretonne donc si je suis
bretonne c'est pour ça que forcément
vous aimer cette musique celtique mais
qu'est ce qu'elle évoque pour vous ce
qu'elle évoque pour moi c'est
véritablement ce sont ce sont des
racines
ce sont des racines profondes et quand
je dis ça c'est pas ça n'a rien à voir
avec une sorte de chauvinisme mais c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui qui ramène à
la terre et je trouve que ce qui est
intéressant
dans cette danse est en tout cas dans ce
projet que j'ai envie de développer
c'est que cette connotation celtique
elle est là parce qu'elle est importante
donc elle est vraiment présente mais en
même temps je pense qu'elle peut
vraiment trouvé un écho et je me rends
compte qu'elle trouve un écho chez
beaucoup de gens parce qu'elle ramène
justement assez à ses racines et je
trouve que dans une période où tout
devient quand même un petit peu
compliqué on essaye de se bien de relire
alors lâchez vos la rade et à des
repères on sait pas trop trop où on va
c'est bien d'avoir ces ses racines quand
je n'avance avait dansé un financement
participatif pour la réalisation de ce
cd quatre titres mais c'est un cd qui va
de toute façon d'après vous qui se fera
parce que ça avance bien évidemment il
ya des musiciens qui sont venus
rejoindre aujourd'hui il ya combien de
musiciens qui sont venus vous rejoindre
participer à ce projet et qui sont ils
ils sont bretons aussi noble alors j'ai
une belle équipe j'ai beaucoup de chance
parce que j'ai avec moi
plusieurs musiciens et la concrètement
pour la réalisation du 4e type donc j'ai
mon ami dave dario qui est chanteur
auteur compositeur que vous connaissez
peut-être avec qui j'ai composé beaucoup
de types de ce projet parce que
effectivement dans un premier temps je
réalise un cap titre mais il ya tout une
création qui existe autour de cette
thématique avoir un grand spectacle pour
un vrai spectacle pour un album pour un
spectacle et c'est vraiment c'est pour
ça que quand je parle de cet album c'est
plutôt un projet dans la mesure où ça
raconte une histoire donc pour revenir
pardon pour répondre à votre question
donc il ya dave dario avec moi j'ai deux
musiciens bretons flûtistes et
violonistes qui s'appelle youn perron et
gwenola l'arrivée et j'ai aussi un
formidable cadeau c'est à dire que j'ai
quelqu'un qui s'appelle steve shine qui
est un percussionniste de grand talent
et qui est reconnue sur le plan
international qui va faire les
arrangements du 4 titres donc là pour
l'instant nous sommes en train de faire
des arrangements mais il travaille sur
les arrangements
donc ça va aller assez vite alors du
coup oui ça va vite c'est à dire que la
la fin du financement participatif c'est
le 14 avril
il semble et on rentre en studio le 14
avril c'est parfait et donc forcément
l'album sortira dans la foulée ça
exactement exactement mais juin on va
dire joint plus tard depuis maintenant
vous travaillé sur ce projet ça va faire
deux ans ça va faire deux ans parce que
donc au départ il ya eu l'écriture de
cette chanson merlin
que j'ai enregistrée et puis j'ai
rencontré un réalisateur avec qui on a
monté le projet de faire ce clip
donc ça a pris un petit peu de temps et
puis après on a on a décidé jeudi on
parce qu'avec ce réalisateur qui est
devenu un ami hervé bramy on s'est dit
que c'était dommage de
de s'arrêter là donc moi toute cette
création finalement tout s'est tu
toutes ces légendes tout c'est ambiance
celtique que je portais en moi depuis de
nombreuses années et bien d'un seul coup
pouf tout est sorti donc toutes les
chansons sont arrivées les unes après
les autres
donc aujourd'hui au tour de ceux de ce
projet il ya quand même il ya 25
chansons
il ya un scénario aussi que j'ai écris
donc j'ai écrit un spectacle sera
musical à la prochaine étape
voilà ce sera la prochaine étape qu'on
comprend c'est toujours un peu compliqué
la création parce que c'est long c'est
compliqué de trouver des financements
c'est pas évident et puis c'est ce que
je vous disais tout à l'heure en fait on
se rend compte aussi d'une chose c'est
que finalement dans un monde où tout va
très très vite
aujourd'hui à tous les niveaux internet
et puis même en termes de consommation
aujourd'hui tout voilà les choses
s'enchaînent très rapidement on se sent
un petit peu en décalage avec avec le
phénomène de la création qui demande du
temps de la maturation et puis
effectivement une mise en oeuvre qui
peut pas se faire comme ça du jour au
lendemain et enfin ça dépend dans quel
concept on se situe mais en tout cas
pour un projet comme ça c'est vrai que
ça prend du temps
donc moi j'ai décidé de faire les choses
les unes après les autres
étape après étape donc c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui j'ai mis en place ce
financement participatif pour un quatre
titres mais derrière il ya tout une
création qui existe voilà donc je garde
effectivement le le le spectacle sous
une forme ou sous une autre
en tête en tout cas aujourd'hui j'ai ce
cap titre qui raconte une histoire et ce
n'est que le début d'une belle aventure
et pour ça il faut aller j'ai besoin de
vue voilà ses appels de balle
roussel donc le site participatif ulule
4000 euros pour financer ce cd 4 titres
et puis pour continuer l aventure de
merlin demers a joué juste une dernière
question de royan vous porter sur les
émissions still the voice est ce que
c'est
est-ce que c'est utile est ce que c'est
important parce que ça booste des
carrières s'oublie vite c'est compliqué
on apprend pas le temps la création
c'est compliqué c'est long
quel regard vous portez vous sur ces
émissions est ce que ça peu sera plus
par exemple aurait pu y participer dans
la pub booster les choses finalement
pourquoi pas parce que ce sont des je
pense qu'avant tout ce sont des
émissions de divertissement on se rend
compte qu'il ya énormément de gens qui
ont beaucoup de talent parce qu'il ya
vraiment des voix quand même
exceptionnel à chaque saison
maintenant effectivement je trouve que
ça rentre bien dans ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure dans ce phénomène
de tout qui va très vite c'est à dire
que finalement ces candidats qui arrive
qu'ils sont qui sont jugées malgré tout
alors c'est vrai qu'il y en a qui tirent
leur épingle du jeu et c'est formidable
et il y en ad'autres je pense pour qui
c'est plus difficile donc je porterai
pas de jugement sur ce type d'émission
parce que je pense qu'encore une fois
aujourd'hui on vit dans un monde où il
n'y a plus vraiment de modèle économique
qui qu'ils soient complètement on va
dire viable donc aujourd'hui finalement
en tant qu'artiste c'est important de
tirer un petit peu toutes les ficelles
et d'essayer de tirer son épingle du jeu
en ouvrant toutes les portes
enfin devant toutes les portes merci en
tout cas banal rossa d'être venu sur le
plateau de méfiance donc pour ceux qui
sont intéressés vraiment bien site
internet et il ya la plateforme de
financement participatif on n'aura cessé
de tiers pendant l'émission
merci beaucoup au maintien des casques
avec une page de loisirs
en cette période de vacances scolaires
les communes multiples ateliers à
destination des enfants à
magny-les-hameaux ces ateliers sont
organisés autour de la thématique femmes
du monde lundi se tenait notamment un
atelier autour de la peinture aux
pigments naturels de quoi faire
découvrir une autre manière de peindre
aux enfants mélanie poquet elodie moines
ces artistes en herbe découvrent
aujourd'hui la technique ton père a une
technique utilisant les pigments
naturels des épices comme le curry le
curcuma mais aussi de l'oeuf
l'intérêt c'est d'inventer la propre
couleur que justement et redécouvrent le
plaisir des matières et aussi comment
sont fabriqués des couleurs à l'origine
qu'ils apprennent en s'amusant et qu'il
ne soit pas juste à utiliser des
peintures d'études acheté en grande
surface
on peut utiliser vraiment toutes les
matières même certains réduits en comme
la carotte la betterave pour obtenir des
choses plus proche de l'aquarelle
une fois les palettes préparer les
enfants peuvent découvrir cette
technique utilisée à la fin du moyen-âge
et au quattrocento le 15ème siècle
italien health américains étaient des
pourris un coeur pur qui s'adonneront
tout ça donne des couleurs pour
connaissez pas avant c'est rigolo et
auprès des nouvelles choses si les
enfants sont ravis c'est aussi le cas
des parents l'attendent paiera n'utilise
que des produits naturels
c'est intéressant parce qu'il n'y a pas
de produits chimiques et deuxième fin en
fait deuxième
les hommes femmes aiment et peuvent les
mettre dans la bouche sariska rien pour
la santé et tous des arguments qui font
que même quand on est tout petit on peut
s'y essayer et pour continuer cette
émission je vous pose maintenant des
idées loisirs alors comme tous les
premiers dimanches du mois il vous est
possible de découvrir complètement la
commanderie des templiers d'elancourt
une visite d'une heure trente pendant
laquelle vous saurez tout sur l'histoire
du site son architecture la visite de la
chapelle et les expositions temporaires
c'est ce dimanche à 15 heures
l'entrée est libre mais les réservations
obligatoires auprès du musée de la ville
une exposition pour continuer celle que
propose jusqu'à samedi
emmanuel mercier de müller à l'espace de
covile de voisins-le-bretonneux
l'artiste présente des oeuvres
figuratives et abstraites son parcours
est atypique
à 27 ans elle quitte son métier dans
l'informatique pour partir en australie
sur la découverte des peintres
aborigènes
elle y reste quatre ans et revient
nourrit d'une nouvelle culture c'est
donc à découvrir jusqu'à ce samedi
l'entrée est libre un tout autre thème
va-t-on trop loin avec le principe de
précaution un débat proposée dans le
cadre des cafés philo ce samedi après
midi à débat proposé par bruno sauvage
dans un premier temps il sera question
de revenir sur la proche culturel de la
question du principe de précaution
et puis dans un second temps la question
sera de savoir si l'on va
ou pas trop loin avec ce principe
l'entrée est libre
cela peut être aussi le lieu de
méditation philosophique le jardin il en
sera en tout cas il sera pardon en tout
cas question de taille fruitière ce
samedi après midi avec l'association
jardins passions partage la nouvelle
association de vente de faux les
activités proposées par l'association
sont gratuites pour les adhérents
l'adhésion à l'association est fixé à 20
euros par an et pour les non adhérents
une participation de 10 euros sera
demandée la séance de ce samedi aura
lieu à elancourt route de montfort chez
un particulier
et elle sera notamment animée par
françois moulin et on termine cet agenda
avec un atelier au musée de la ville ce
samedi après midi c'est béton avec des
jeux de découverte une visite autour du
musée il sera possible de fabriquer son
propre presse papier en béton l'atelier
est à 3 euros tarif plein 12 euros tarif
réduit et pour les enfants bar vend de
moins de 12 ans la présence d'un adulte
est obligatoire voilà pour les citer
le seul les 5 et 6 mars prochains la
ferme de bel ébat à guillon pro propose
nous attendrons que le soleil revienne à
nicolas gerber rencontrer l'auteur
godefroy ségal
comme chaque année ce féru d'histoire
revient avec une nouvelle création cette
année il s'intéresse à l' empire avec un
spectacle qui sera présenté les 5 et 6
mars à la ferme de bel ébat à guyancourt
voici godefroy ségal dans le kiosque il
nous parle de nous attendrons que le
soleil revienne
voilà plus de soleil l'avion ainsi notre
héros fabrice val sert à bâle casino del
dongo
il est justement de se donner la peine
de l'aide
lorsque les français furent chassés
élu deux ans lorsque tout à coup un
général nommé bonaparte descendit du
mont st bernard et entravant milan un
spectacle un petit peu particulier car
constituent en fait de deux pièces
distinctes mais qui s'enchaîneront en
fait même sans entracte l'une après
l'autre
en première partie le s'en lavera tout
ça un spectacle que j'ai construit
autour de la bataille d'austerlitz
en fait des débuts de lempire de
l'épopée de l' empire et en deuxième
partie une adaptation que j'ai effectués
sur la chartreuse de parme de stendhal
on part des débuts mais alors pas
forcément se focalisant sur ça mais sur
l'aller les grandes aventures des
guerres napoléoniennes mais avec
effectivement le le versant plutôt
guerrier est sur le départ avec les
grandes victoires comme austerlitz et
puis avec la chartreuse de parme et d'un
de ce jeune garçon fabrice del dongo qui
a grandi sous les auspices de l' empire
et qui a participé à la dernière
bataille waterloo fabrice grandi entre
l'amour de sa mère et celui de sa jeune
tante déjà veuve la comtesse pietranera
qui adorait plus que tout cet enfant
elles étaient émerveillés des grâces de
fabrice est épouvanté de son ignorance
ils ne savaient ni lire ni écrire des
grand chose d'autre d'ailleurs
c'est une façon pour nous après le 93 de
victor hugo de continuer en fait cette
ces grandes questions sur sur les débuts
de la république française stendhal
illustre fermement et très très bien ce
que peut être ce paradoxe de l' empire
c'est à dire comment finalement on peut
se faire roi alors qu'on défend encore
les lois de la république
hier soir il était 6 heures 7 minutes et
nous sommes
7 je me promenais sur le bord du lac
tout à coup à une hauteur immense havas
droite
j'ai vu un mec avec de napoléon il
volait majestueusement c'était les gens
vers la suisse et par conséquent père
paris nous attendrons que ça là ils
reviennent très bonne question
en travaillant sur la bataille
d'austerlitz on la figure toujours par
ce symbole que napoléon lui-même lui
avait donné c'est à dire que la victoire
française a été écrasante à partir du
moment où le soleil a percé c'est à dire
que les brumes ont caché les soldats
français
jusqu'au moment où il fallait que les
soldats français puissent voir et le
soleil est arrivé exactement au moment
où les armées françaises en avaient
besoin
et on parle toujours du soleil
d'austerlitz j'étais troublé de ce
soleil d'austerlitz avec cette fin dans
la chartreuse de parme qui se passent
totalement dans l'obscurité dents
longues
j'avais envie d'avoir ces deux pendants
entre le soleil et l'obscurité
je le rejoins d'empereur c'est au sirop
d'italie j'avais tant d'amitié pour ton
mari j'avais passé par là et il ya ce
côté de vide qui vient presse est cet
embrasement mais totalement passionnée
mais qui n'a pas été que de la violence
c'est un dalle le rappelle c'est à dire
dès le début de la chartreuse de parme
il rappelle que l'italie finalement a
été libéré par les troupes françaises
il faut jamais oublier que la france la
république française apportaient quand
même une émancipation comme les peuples
européens on n'avait jamais vécu
oui centres en france par contrarié et
des partis avec la ferme intention de
parler à l'empereur mais jamais une lui
était venue à l'esprit que ce fut chose
difficile de ville en ville
il essaya vainement de s'engager arrivé
dans le nord
un officier l'envoya à la prison de
braine l'alleud
fabrice d'abord est donnée puis furieux
ne comprenait absolument rien à ce qu'il
veut arriver au début le spectacle
n'aurait été que le sens lavera tous à
la pièce que moi j'ai écrites sur sur la
bataille d'austerlitz et sur l'épopée de
l' empire
il se trouve que quand j'ai écrit ce
texte là et quand j'ai relu la
chartreuse en me disant tiens il faut
que je retourne un peu du côté de
stendhal pour voir un peu ce qu'il
disait lui de cette époque j'ai été
étonné de voir les correspondances et
j'espère que le sens lavera tout ça
finalement de de raconter un peu lent
pire aux gens par un spectacle qui va
les emporter dans dans les émotions dans
la façon dont ces petits français se
sont levés et ont sillonné mais l'europe
entière à une période où les gens
bougeaient peu où c'était pas si facile
que ça effectivement d'aller loin
combien de jeunes français ont traversé
l'europe entière ont été jusqu'en egypte
ont été enfin je veux dire ça a changé
tout les mentalités ça a changé
c'est pour ça que le 19e après a été
énormément en orient a été sa hausse à
tout ouvert et j'espère que ça pourra
éclairer effectivement la chartreuse de
parme d'une autre façon la femme du
julier belle flamande de 36 ans n'avait
nulle envie de voir fusillé un aussi
joli garçon
madame jean temps canon on se bat pas
moi faites moi sortir d'ici et je suis
reçue en honneur de revenir dans la
prison dès qu'on aura cessé de se battre
du début juillet c'est une donnée
centaines de francs je mettrai met la
pression sur chacun des et du caporal tu
pourras plus voir partir de prisons pour
raconter ce qui a pu provoquer la
révolution les ennemis qu'elle a pu
s'attirer et comment finalement cette
armée française avec son chef napoléon a
dû finalement envahir l'europe entière
et bien au delà pour pour contrer tout
ça eh ben c'est pas facile parce qu'on
on raconte beaucoup de batailles la
chartreuse de parme c'est pareil c'est
un roman c'est pas du théâtre c'est un
roman on arrive à leur faire sentir
effectivement la la violence des combats
là la prouesse des hommes le courage des
hommes
les costumes pas comme on les attend pas
porter en tout cas comme on pourrait les
attendre des éléments de décor
rien n'est pas très vendeur mais
pourtant on va beaucoup plus loin sans
chaussures de là mais ne raconte jamais
de mauvais compte d'un gentilhomme du
milan des visées en marche le baromètre
c'est trop bête
écoute moi bien je te donne les avis des
hussards mort avant-hier dans la prison
et après nous attendrons que le soleil
revienne c'est catherine qui va nous
apporter ses lumières sur le plateau du
kiosque
comme tous les mercredis je vous propose
de retrouver la chronique cinéphiles et
nous démarrons avec les avis de
spectateurs au micro d' elodie moines
que c'était plein d'action et s'était
trompé moi j'ai bien aimé beaucoup
d'action moi je suis plutôt génération
casimir mais ses vrais cheveux isaiah
c'était très intéressant
c'était bien même si ya bien peu je vais
aussi aller quand même des choses
romantiques
si quelque chose nous voulons parfois le
début j'ai très très bon film
d'animation en espérant qu'ils aient de
suite elle c'était super les cascades
ils sentent bien et beaucoup d'action en
france à mon film d'un bon film d'action
on rapporte le rappeur y aura par
ailleurs apple avec les yamakasi donc
pas mal une bonne action qui suit bien
bon dénouement à la fin c'est vraiment
très bien c'est un très bon film voilà
plein d'émotions
ça joue entre le fantastique je
réalisais seront sélectionnés je
trouvais quand même vachement bien donc
il ya de super image je trouve et je
crois que l'histoire elle est magnifique
quand même c'est pas mal un moment
c'était un peu un peu triste c'est un
bon film voilà spectateurs emballés 1
cette semaine allaient nous poursuivons
avec le coup de coeur ben professionnels
du 7e art ce soir direction le cinéma
des clayes-sous-bois cette semaine à
l'espace philippe maury nous vous
présentons notre coup de coeur papa ou
maman on vous avez une ce soir pour vous
annoncer un divorce
1 ils divorcent et vont tout faire pour
ne pas avoir la garde des enfants
voici le pitch du film qu'ils se sont
florence et vincent leroy modèle de
réussite sociale et conjugale jusque
dans leur manière très civilisée
d'annoncer leur séparation à des rennais
tout se gâte lorsque leurs trois enfants
sont vives au parfum et qu'on propose
aux pères comme à la mer une promotion à
l'étranger
le couple se déclare alors la guerre
travail magic si on n'avait pas vu avec
tata est suspecté dit sa solution
désactiver tu veux la guerre mais
apparemment ce qui va venir à moi je
veux la guerre tu veux si je veux la
guerre tu veux la guerre des courants
tomic est à feu c'est bien c'est trop
con oui mais ça allège chantage sabotage
d'une fête annoncée de yaourts les
parents déchaînés se lance dans un jeu
de massacre régressif le couple marina
foïs et laurent lafitte assure dans la
surenchère s'attendre à mieux schumacher
et aulas
il commit dynamique drôle et sortant des
sentiers battus on ne va pas bouder
notre plaisir c'est clair très dynamique
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
nous avoir suivis et rendez vous
mercredi prochain même jour même heure
il sera question du printemps des poètes
d'ici là garder l'esprit ouvert et
curieux bonne soirée une bonne semaine